say well you know you've got the person
who's got a who's turned their their
social media into a very self-absorbed
sort of platform that's a lot and that's
a that's a lot and then even in amongst
that it's like well I mean to a degree
if it's your social media and you are
the prime element within it you know of
course it would be a bit self-absorbed
but yeah but I think there's more nuance
to it than that and it's not just a pic
on say you know the gals that are taking
all the sexy selfies and all that kind
of stuff there's the the dudes that do
essentially the same equivalent and it's
all in a you know often it could be in a
response to drive attention towards
themselves but what do you why do you
want that attention in the first place
and of course that's something you can't
know until you know the person exactly
well a lot of girls make a living off of
it a hundred percent yeah there's a lot
of girls that they do like sponsored
tweets or sponsored an Instagram posts
once they get new leads are making a
living off of Instagram that way first
like that got famous like for girls it's
like girls with big asses and there's
one girl that I just started following
her whole instagrams her ass I mean
that's it man I was thinking it was a
terrible thing to think but I was
thinking if a dog ever came over and bit
her ass she'd be out of work that's it
it's [ __ ] up she's have a an arcing
spray of [ __ ] gel shooting adverts you
should have Kevlar pants on everywhere
should go London I have what will you
give me per cheek on insurance I mean
she has a tremendous ass don't get me
wrong but it's just weird when there's
this like one here's my heart that
essentially defines your identity like
this does which which is weirder that
creates a stone this this person with
this fantastic monumental epic level ass
is out there taking photos of it and
putting it out there for people to see
or that people not only continue to look
at it
but more flock to this this religious
icon of an ass apparently yeah well it
doesn't get old apparent it never gets
old
no not for dudes I mean for girls is
there like one but I guess it's ABS is
it ABS like what is the one body part
turn to Jamie Jamie yeah hey tell us
about
but for girls it's a wallet how fat as
well it's kind of fat wat but uh and
also it wouldn't be surprised that the
women in terms of that that kind of
shallow aspect of social media in that
way could could make more impact out of
it because even when you look at say all
the men's mag women's Maggie's and all
that kind of stuff like women want to
look at hot women yeah right so women
are even driven to look at holla where
of course obviously driven to look at
hot women well women know about filters
too like oh this [ __ ] is using filters
look at her that is not what she looks
like and then oh my god she looks like a
cartoon face look at her face and then
they're trying to find out what filter
that was yeah that's a beauty filter
what Cameron did she use yeah if girls
found out that there was like one camera
that really did it there would be every
girl would use that one phone that has
that one camp exactly okay they nailed
it I guess they're all pretty good now
but if there was like one standout phone
that took better selfies mmm like that
would be the one that they used oh it
would be a marketing avalanche towards
yeah right that demographic for sure
like your your bri r phone like if you
have a phone then the camera on the back
it's always more powerful than the
selfie kiss with a bigger lens and four
chicks that's [ __ ] [ __ ] like they
need the other way you need like
multiple lenses you can choose which one
you need they're like I know what my
friends look like I see them I want to
see myself selfie sticks if there was
dudes only dudes on the planet there'd
be no selfie sticks that [ __ ] would have
never been invented
you know like so no if we found if it
was only men and we found a guy with a
selfie stick that would be the guy we
[ __ ] is this did you get injured is
this a walking stick this is a portable
baton in case you get attacked are you
using that to take photos inside of a
bear cave yeah cuz you're not about to
go in you want to make sure what you
know where the Grizzly is or you uh you
know putting that thing around corners
yeah that rabbit is get it is that were
you doing cuz if not I got a problem
with this
my arms are sure lucky dudes with selfie
sticks that is a dark thing there's
something about it like holding it up
I'm in front of bla bla bla
it doesn't make any sense like why is it
okay for me to take a selfie with a
regular selfie lens mhm but it's a
problem if it dude as a selfie stick I
don't know it just seems a bit obnoxious
yeah perhaps well it seems that way I
can't say that I have a reason why it
makes sense me you know hey maybe it's
simply because we view it as something
that that or we see women do it more and
so we think that a man is somehow doing
something well it's likely I don't know
if a man gets fillers in his face you
ever see like a older dude who gets
fillers in his face like bro I didn't
want to pull them aside come here I'm
sure I have yeah you wanna go no just
don't you're gonna be wrinkled this is
just it you're 65 years old you gotta
let it go let it go it's letting go on
its own anyways but some some gals can
kind of pull it off and you feel bad for
them but they still look kind of pretty
so you know personally myself I'm not
really all that into the especially
manipulating the face like that for
anyone I just think that it's it's one
the potential for it to go really badly
real biz there and to it just I think
that people you don't have to look
perfect to be a beautiful person yeah
yeah your person that I mean like your
personality is at least as important as
the way you look and if your personality
is such that you need to shoot plastic
into your face in order to feel good
about yourself you know I've got to go
oh like what's happening there but below
the surface it could be a indicator of
something more serious that that no
matter how much filler how nice it could
look maybe there's still gonna be an
issue
per se so it's also one of those things
just like anorexia or bodybuilders that
can never get big enough where they have
body dysmorphia people don't know what
they really look like do you do you know
about the Fibonacci sequence the numbers
right yeah it's the golden ratio it
actually applies to facial features
see you can find something on that now
there is one of the see documentary on
that right and at the time I there was
something about symmetry mm-hmm and
Elizabeth Hurley when they made that
thing was considered like one of the
most beautiful women in the world by the
sin by the mathematics of it all she's
still why I don't doubt it yeah that
chicks like 88 years old she's still hot
as [ __ ]